three of our core four have left town
and now somehow The Gargoyle King has
learned how to use his little twigs to
open doors
let's bunker down together and talk it
all out on Sweetwater seekers hello
there River babes
I'm your host Liana Galera and this is
your Sweetwater secrets after-show for
episode 306 chapter 41 Manhunter now my
head is still spinning and my nose is a
little stuffy from crying a bit during
this episode so hit the comments right
now and tell me your initial thoughts
now we have a lot a lot to get through
so let's dive right into the jam-packed
headlines in this week's blue and gold
breakdown fresh off his brush with The
Gargoyle King jug had returned to the
bunker and told his boo buddy that he
saw a masked group all standing around
and worshipping this mysteriously twiggy
figure like they were a gang a gang of
gargoyle turns out Joaquin has
officially slithered away from the
serpents and joined this gargoyle gang
and now the Jughead has discovered that
the warden was also playing G&G he
confronted Joaquin for some answers
Joaquin said that the man in the black
suit was giving the warden his gng
commands but the confrontation between
Jughead and Hyrum proved to be
frustratingly a few child you're The
Gargoyle King Hiram I'm not a
sixteen-year-old nerd as much as I
despise Hyrum I don't think he's the man
in black do you tell me in the comments
moving on the Serpent's were shocked to
see a blue lift Joaquin show up on
juggies doorstep alright peen Joaquin
overall you were fine I guess
and over on the manhunt front veronica
was still determined to prove her man's
innocence and she discovered the
unedited footage that showed sheriff
Minetta bribing the shadow lake boys to
lie under oath and blame Archie for
murder
that's not proof of course I don't know
what is now those lying boys were
actually hiding out in the mines at
shadow lake but Archie and Kevin found
them a few moments too late it seems
like sheriff Minetta killed them all
before they could admit the truth
meanwhile Betty tricked all the parents
of Riverdale to meet up in V speakeasy
and even though we were all momentarily
too
- by the fact that this town has
seriously the most attractive adults
ever been he reminded us that mmm this
is serious business
someone in this room is a murderer
Penelope blossom threw out a lame lie
and basically blamed the poison chalice
controversy completely on Daryl doily
Dylan's dad dead yeah turns out Daryl
didn't commit suicide he was poisoned
and although Penelope denied Betty's
accusations sheriff Keller admitted that
he was the one to cover up the murder
and her own mom wrote an article
supporting the lie and the gargoyle King
apparently got tired of lurking in the
woods so he decided to pay a visit to
the Cooper household instead with the
glorified stick figure down in the
living room Alison Betty were shocked to
see a familiar face climbing through the
bedroom window gurgle King is in the
house now by the end of the episode
three of our core four were out of the
picture Jughead joined his best bud
Archie and the two of them decided to
skip town and ride the rails and Alice
Cooper committed the biggest parental
sin you could make in Riverdale she sent
betty off to live with the sisters of
quiet mercy there's no safer place for
you now Betty quickly realized she
definitely isn't safe
goodness gracious that was a lot of
information to pack into one episode so
let's take a deep breath and channel our
attention into seven seconds in heaven
now as much as I love it when Betty and
Jughead share smooch and this episode
had a damn good one there is something
about a simple yet sweet forehead kiss
that really makes me swoon oh don't even
get me started on their nose nuzzles but
we're gonna mostly focus on Veronica and
Archie right now because this was a very
big episode for them things with barchi
started out fun as the duo shared some
bunkers sexy times and Jughead and
Betty's bunker sexy time bed and that
makes it official that bunker is now the
sexiest place in Riverdale poor Dilton
would probably be turning over in his
grave right now if he knew that his
super secret bunker has now turned into
the speakeasy of spooning I mean this
bunker is the only place in town we can
get a modicum of privacy but it seems
like that was bar cheese last canoodle
for a while now despite the fact that
Veronica found the evidence to prove
Archie's innocence and sweetly set up an
over-the-top welcome home party for his
return he regretfully told her that it
was time for him to leave town so he
could escape Hiram's vicious clutches
once and for all goodbye Veronica their
tearful goodbye was gut-wrenching
and I definitely reached for a tissue or
two but even though it was a tough one
to watch I still have hope for their
future does we're endgame Archie but now
let's dry our tears and without those
claws because it's time to unleash my
hisses and kisses for episode 306 my
first and biggest hit of the night goes
to sheriff Mineta for seemingly
murdering those boys and for scaring
Josie so badly that she had a seizure
and hisses go to the fact that we'd
never ever got to check up on Josie and
see her in the hospital either Ethel
practically has a wing in the hospital
named after her in that place and I just
needed to see for myself if our pretty
kitty is okay
hisses to Alice for banishing Betty away
to the sisters of quiet mercy don't
pretend like you're doing this for her
own good we all know that betty was
catching on to your lives and you're
just trying to get her out of the way
but a teeny kiss goes to Alice's Mama
Bear instincts in the bedroom
hisses - meeting Reggie Mantle's dad
Marty and - his pathetic response to
Betty's confrontation I would never hit
my son you're a crap liar in a creep and
I hope that gargoyle cake makes you
ascend next hisses - the fact that Hiram
replaced Veronica's portrait in his
office with one of himself uh how about
one of your wife Hiram's how frickin
conceited can you be none of your
business it hisses - the confusion
behind Darrell Doyle's death doilies
death I don't even know anymore I
thought we were supposed to be focusing
on Dilton and/or principal featherheads
death stop giving us more questions
instead of answers k thanks switching
over to kisses kisses goes to
Riverdale's epic omage to the movie
scream now for all you young river babes
out there Skeet Ulrich starred in the
1996 horror flick where he played the
seemingly sweet and supportive boyfriend
but in reality he and his BFF for the
killers all along
we all got mad so does this mean that
Riverdale is trying to tell us that FP
is behind all of this GMG craziness it
sure seems like Betty is starting to
think so or is all this just a nice
little nod to Skeets big-screen pass
already played that game remember tell
me in the comments right now kisses to
Kevin and Archie's bromance during this
episode it was really nice to see this
friendship on screen and it was even
sweeter to see their dad's team up as
well kisses - dr. curdle jr. you may be
oh so creepy and susceptible to bribes
in small bills but you're really helping
the team out lately so good on you doc
kisses - Jughead being in charge
honestly I don't know what it is but it
seems like every time Jughead utters a
command to his serpents like this one
come on I always get a big kick out of
seeing him rock his crown and kisses to
Camilla Mendez for her heart-wrenching
yet stellar performance in this episode
she did such a brilliant job that I'm
even giving a pass to the fact that the
writers made her say this no need to
think me love her and now we're done
that was a big one and I can't wait to
read all of your kisses kisses comments
and theories and see what you guys had
to say during our next Sweetwater
Secrets preview show for episode 307
chapter 42 the man in black you know
what to do river babes give this video a
like and then hit subscribe so you never
miss an episode and then ride the rails
down to the comments and tell me all of
your kisses and kisses from 3:06 do you
think Riverdale's scream omage means
that FP is guilty of something who do
you think the man in the black suit is
and what did you think of the VAR Chee
breakup oh and how will Betty handle her
stay and the sisters of quiet gargoyles
I can't wait to see you have to say
adore you river babes the bite
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]